I was just corrected that it's definitely not Pascal. It's Pascal. And I got called out on the last episode for mispronouncing that. And we had homemade apricot. Is that apricot? Apricot ice cream, yes. Apricot ice cream. And it was divine.
我刚被纠正，那绝对不是 Pascal。是 Pascal。上一期节目中，我因为发音错误而被指正了。我们还吃了自制的杏子。那是杏子吗？杏子冰淇淋，是的。杏子冰淇淋。太好吃了。
I was in Rwanda for six weeks and I wrote this. What happened was the company that we had connections to, they ran all the ATMs in the country. And I started doing it in Java and it was just so awful. And then my boss at the time suggested that I do it in Ruby. And that was a fantastic decision
我在卢旺达呆了六周，并写了这个。事情是这样的，我们有联系的那家公司运营着该国所有的自动取款机。我一开始用 Java 编写，实在是太糟糕了。然后我当时的Boss建议我用 Ruby 来写。那真是一个绝佳的决定
because Ruby is great for string handling. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 152, recorded on October 18th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Jonathan O'Connor and chat with him about his journey from C++ to Java to Ruby and back to C++, as well as his programming experience with Ruby in Rwanda, Quines, and more. Let us introduce our guest first. Let me hop over because I actually went and found Mr. Jonathan O'Connor's bio from Meeting C++, which is a conference I know that you've given a couple different talks at, I believe. This one is entitled Hands-On C++ 20 Ranges, Code Routines, Concepts, and Modules. And the bio... No, that's not me.
因为 Ruby 非常适合处理字符串。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 152 期，录制于 2023 年 10 月 18 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起采访了乔纳森·奥康纳（Jonathan O'Connor），与他聊了聊他从 C++ 到 Java、再到 Ruby、最后又回到 C++ 的历程，以及他在卢旺达用 Ruby 编程的经历、奎因（Quine）程序等等。让我们先介绍我们的嘉宾。让我切换一下，因为我特意去找到了乔纳森·奥康纳先生在 C++ 会议（Meeting C++）上的简介，我知道你曾在该会议上做过好几次不同的演讲，对吧。这场演讲的题目是“动手实践 C++ 20 范围、协程、概念和模块”。而这份简介……不，那不是我。
No? Oh, no, concepts, and modules. And the bio... No, that's not me. No? Oh, no, wait. Correction. That is a very poorly placed advertisement right on top of your profile picture and your name. And then in very small... I guess it's the same font size as the bio. It says, talks, colon, Alice's Adventures in Template Land.
不是吗？哦，不对，是概念和模块。而这份简介……不，那不是我。不是吗？哦，等等，纠正一下。那是一个位置非常尴尬的广告，正好贴在你的头像和名字的正上方。然后是用非常小的字……我猜它和简介的字号一样大。上面写着：演讲，冒号，“爱丽丝梦游模板仙境”。
But I guess this is an advertisement for a book, which, I mean, I'm pretty sure it's very unintentional on Jens' part, the organizer of the conference and the designer of the website. I'm actually, I got to take a screenshot of this so we can put this in the show notes just so that people don't come at me for thinking like it is, it's definitely, and it also, it has no border. So like on Compiler Explorer, they have ads at the top in the banner, but they're always in like a little green kind of highlighted thing. It's very clear that this is an ad. This is just like a hyperlinked image. And if you look closely
但我想这是一个关于某本书的广告，也就是说，我非常确定这绝不是会议组织者兼网站设计者延斯（Jens）的本意。实际上，我得截个图，把它放到节目Shownotes里，免得人们跑来质疑我，它绝对……而且它连边框都没有。就像在 Compiler Explorer 上一样，他们的顶部横幅上有广告，但它们通常在一个带有绿色高亮的小方框里。很明显这是一个广告。这纯粹就像是一个带超链接的图像。如果你仔细看
in the bottom left-hand corner, it says capital A-D in what looks like size 7 font. Anyways, whether that stays in or not, I mean, personally, I know Jonathan because we met. I mean, I believe you were
左下角，用大约 7 号字大小写着大写的 A-D。不管怎样，不管这个广告留不留下来，我个人认识乔纳森是因为我们见过面。我的意思是，我相信你当时也
at the conference too. This was 2019, meeting C++. The three of us had dinner at a Vietnamese restaurant. Oh, that's right. About 10 minutes walk. That's right. And I think both of you at the time were not drinking any alcohol, which seems to have changed during your road trip.
在会议上。那是 2019 年的 Meeting C++。我们三个在一家越南餐厅吃过晚餐。哦，对。步行大约 10 分钟。没错。而且我记得你们俩当时都没有喝酒，不过在你们的公路旅行期间，这种情况似乎已经改变了。
I mean, for 50% of bryce is still for 50 percent yeah bryce is still on that uh you know the golden path to success is that the first time that we met jonathan i think it's probably the only time we've met in person i don't think i don't think we've met since no however i met jonathan for sec. I believe it was the second time because I have a sister that currently lives in Dublin, Ireland, and you live just outside of Dublin. And my sister and I went and visited you at your lovely home and you hosted us. You had some family there. And the highlight, of course, enjoying Jonathan's lovely company was amazing. But the highlight was something I don't even, I actually think I said I was going to tweet about it. And then I didn't tweet about it. It was, and if I recall the flavor, it was apricot. Am I, am I correct in that? It was, yes, apricot, as we say in Ireland.
我是说，对布莱斯来说，50% 的情况……对，50% 仍然……布莱斯仍然在走那条“走向成功的康庄大道”。那是我们第一次见到乔纳森吗？我想这可能是我们唯一一次面基，我觉得我们之后再没见过。不对，不过我实际上见过乔纳森第二次。我想那是第二次，因为我有个姐姐目前住在爱尔兰都柏林，而你恰好住在都柏林郊外。我和姐姐去拜访了你可爱的家，你还招待了我们。你的一些家人也在那儿。当然，最棒的亮点是享受乔纳森热情的陪伴，这太棒了。但最大的亮点是我甚至……其实我当时说过我要发条推文来着。结果我没发。那是……如果我没记错那个口味的话，是杏子。我没记错吧？是的，杏子，正如我们在爱尔兰所说的那样。
I've discovered that I've been pronouncing all these words. I was just corrected that it's definitely not Pascoal. It's Pas-cal. And I got called out on the last episode for mispronouncing that. And we had homemade apricot. Is that apricot? Apricot ice cream, yes.
我发现我把所有这些词都发错音了。我刚被纠正，那绝对不是 Pascoal（帕斯科尔）。是 Pas-cal（帕斯卡）。上一期节目中，我因为把这个词读错而被指正了。我们还吃了自制的杏子。那是杏子吗？杏子冰淇淋，是的。
Apricot ice cream. And it was divine. And that was, I think, the second time we met. But yes, back to this bio. It reads, in 1998, I joined, I'm'm gonna mess this one up glockenspiel no that was 1988 1988 if it's then it's maybe i wrote that wrong or something but no no no i just have uh what do you call it not dyslexia there's a word for it with numbers called uh what is it called? Dyscalcula. Dyscalcula.
杏子冰淇淋。太好吃了。那大约是我们第二次见面。不过等等，回到这份简介上。上面写着：1998 年，我加入了……我又要把它读砸了，Glockenspiel（格洛肯斯皮尔）……不，那是 1988 年，1988 年。如果那是真的，也许是我把日期写错了或者别的什么。不过不不不，我只是有……怎么说呢，不是失读症，数字方面有一种专门的词，叫做……叫什么来着？计算障碍。计算障碍。
Ah, okay. Who knows? I just misread it. Okay. But Glockenspiel, yeah, I joined Glockenspiel in 1988. I had two friends of mine were working there, and they recommended me to their boss. And I had a 40-minute conversation with them and was hired. that was how people used to get hired in the old good old 40 minutes 40 minutes yeah how many leak code questions in that 40 minutes you know how many how many linked lists did you have to reverse
啊，好吧。谁知道呢？我只是看错了。好吧。不过 Glockenspiel，对，我在 1988 年加入了 Glockenspiel。我有两个朋友在那儿工作，他们把我推荐给了他们的老板。我和他们聊了 40 分钟就被录用了。在过去的美好时光里，人们就是这样被录用的。40 分钟，40 分钟，是的。在这 40 分钟里有多少道力扣（LeetCode）题目？你知道的，你得反转多少个链表？
i don't think any, actually. Wow. But yeah, you worked there? Yeah, I worked there for a few years. And I wrote, yeah, that's where I learned C++. And two of my fellow colleagues there, they worked on the compiler on the C front, which was the predecessor to an actual proper compiler. It would generate C front, which was, you know, the predecessor to an actual proper compiler. It would generate C code,
我想一道都没有。哇。不过，你在那儿工作过？对，我在那儿工作了好几年。我写过……对，我就是在那儿学会 C++ 的。我的两个同事，他们当时在 C front 编译器上工作，C front 是真正意义上的现代编译器的前身。它会生成 C front 代码，也就是真正意义上的现代编译器的前身。它会生成 C 代码，
which you'd then get a C compiler to compile to assembler or machine code. But yeah, there was Martin O'Riordan, who was the only member of the Irish, from Ireland, who was on the standards committee for many, many years. And he helped to write the first, Microsoft's first C++ compiler back in like 1990, 1991. And John Caves, who I suspect Bryce has met John Caves.
然后你再用 C 编译器将其编译成汇编语言或机器码。不过话说回来，还有马丁·奥里ordan（Martin O'Riordan），他是委员会里多年来唯一的爱尔兰籍标准委员会成员。他协助编写了微软在 1990 年、1991 年左右推出的第一个 C++ 编译器。还有约翰·凯夫斯（John Caves），我猜布莱斯应该见过约翰·凯夫斯。
Yes, I have. He's still on the standards committee. And he's still working for Microsoft. And the two of them were in Glockenspiel at the time. What a time and what a group of folks to get to work with. It was a lot of fun. And yeah, I mean, I worked on a GUI framework for it. We wrote a library where you could create Windows programs
是的，我见过。他现在仍然是标准委员会成员，并且仍在微软工作。他们俩当时都在 Glockenspiel。那真是一个时代，也是一群绝佳的共事伙伴。那段经历非常有趣。是的，我当时负责一个图形用户界面（GUI）框架。我们编写了一个库，通过它你可以创建 Windows 程序，
and also OS2 programs, which is another operating system that has come and gone. And I then got involved a lot in education so i would i would go off and train a company for a week in how to write good c++ uh as it was in the day um and yeah the language was so small and we had i I think, we had no standard library. We had no string class. There was a coroutines library that shipped with Seafront, which was in, I think, the first edition of Strewstrup.
还可以创建 OS/2 程序，这也是一个已经成为过去的操作系统。后来我投入了大量精力做培训教育工作，我会去一家公司花上一周时间培训他们如何编写优质的 C++ 代码——正如当时的规范那样。是的，当时的语言非常小巧，而且我们当时，我想，没有任何标准库。我们连字符串（string）类都没有。Cfront 附带了一个协程库，我想那是斯特劳斯特鲁普（Stroustrup）第一版书里的内容。
There's a chapter at the very back of the book that that describes how to use it and and that of course disappeared in the second edition and and later editions and finally we've got back some kind of what we've got i'm not sure if the if the coroutines that we have now are are the same or quite different from the ones that were back in this library it's a long time ago and famously or not famously, but according to the bio, you left the world of C++ for Java. And then Ruby. Although Ruby, I love Ruby.
书的最后几章描述了如何使用它，当然，这在第二版及以后的版本中就消失了。最后我们终于找回了某种……我们现在拥有的东西，我不确定我们现在拥有的协程是和当年的那个库完全一样，还是大不相同。那已经是很久以前的事了。而且，根据简介所说（无论这算不算出名），你为了 Java 离开 C++ 世界，然后又转到了 Ruby。尽管 Ruby，我非常喜欢 Ruby。
Ruby is a lovely language. What do you call it? A not derivative language, a child language, if you will, of small talk, which I think most Ruby people know, but maybe there's some that don't. But was his name Mats? Was a huge fan of Smalltalk. And there's a bunch of stuff in Ruby that is basically completely borrowed
Ruby 是一门可爱的语言。怎么说呢？它是一门衍生语言，或者说可以说是 Smalltalk 的子代语言，我想大多数 Ruby 程序员都知道这一点，但也许有些人不知道。Mats（松本行弘）的名字叫什么来着？他是 Smalltalk 的超级粉丝。Ruby 中有很多东西基本上完全借鉴了
from the Smalltalk model. So you did that for how many years, 10 to 15? No, I did it for about six or seven um and that was that was just ruby or it was just yeah it was ruby was i the first project i got to write in ruby was i wrote a little a little translator uh for atm messages um and i did that in rwanda which was was great fun uh wait wait i want to understand here you did that in Rwanda, which was great fun. Wait, wait, wait. I want to understand here.
Smalltalk 的模型。所以你干了多少年，10 到 15 年？不，我大约干了六七年。那是只有 Ruby 吗？对，就是 Ruby。我用 Ruby 编写的第一个项目是一个小型的 ATM 消息转换器。我在卢旺达完成的，非常有趣。等等，等等，我想弄明白这一点：你在卢旺达做这个，这非常有趣。等等，等等，我想弄明白这一点。
You did that for the Rwanda market? Or you did that while you went to Rwanda? I was in Rwanda for six weeks and I wrote this. What happened was the company that we had connections to, they ran all the atms in the country and that happened to be i think at the time in in 2010 they had 14 atms in a country of 10 million people wait 14 14 1 4 yes wow and that's about one one per what 800 000 or something like or something like that? Something like that, yes, exactly, exactly. And the company had bought another 10 ATMs, but those ATMs were not quite compatible with their server software. And if they wanted to update their server,
你是为卢旺达市场做的这个？还是说你去了卢旺达顺便做的？我在卢旺达呆了六周，并写了这个。事情是这样的，我们有联系的那家公司运营着该国所有的自动取款机，当时在 2010 年，我想他们在拥有 1000 万人口的国家里只有 14 台自动取款机。等等，14 台？14 台，1，4，是的。哇，那大概是八十万人里才有一台，或者类似的情况？差不多就是这样，千真万确。那家公司又买另外 10 台自动取款机，但那些自动取款机与他们的服务器软件不太兼容。如果他们想更新服务器，
they could get a module for their server software, but that module would cost like 50 grand. And they thought, nah, they'll get somebody like me to do it for a few weeks. I'll just write a little translation program that sits in the middle on a little netbook. And it listens for messages from the atm and it listens for messages from the the server and it just translates most of the messages are the same so it just goes all the way through it's passed through but there's a few type there's a few
他们可以为服务器软件购买一个模块，但那个模块要花大约 5 万美元。他们觉得，才不呢，他们会找像我这样的人花几周时间来搞定。我只需编写一个小型转换程序，让它运行在一台小笔记本电脑上作为中间件。它监听来自 ATM 的消息，也监听来自服务器的消息，然后进行转换。大部分消息都是一样的，所以直接透传过去就行，但有几种类型、有几条
messages that have to be tweaked um and uh and i started doing it in java and it was just so awful and then um my boss of the time suggested that i do it in ruby and that was a fantastic decision because ruby is great for string handling and slicing and all that kind of stuff so it was just so much easier um than java this is very true for for leak coding purposes sometimes ruby is the best uh language for speed slash length because it has a ton of convenience methods on strings like uh t o underscore i and like t o underscore b i believe and that one is super useful because it's like uh to base and then you provide the base or so yeah if you have like a string number it will actually maybe that's on
消息需要微调。我一开始用 Java 编写，实在是太糟糕了。然后，我当时的 Boss 建议我用 Ruby 来写，那真是一个绝佳的决定，因为 Ruby 非常适合处理字符串、切片以及所有类似的操作，所以写起来比 Java 容易太多了。这对于刷力扣（LeetCode）来说非常真实，有时 Ruby 是速度/代码长度方面最好的语言，因为它在字符串上有很多便利方法，比如 `to_i` 以及我记得的 `to_b`。其中一个超级有用，就像是 `to_base`，然后你提供进制数。所以，如果你有一个数字字符串，它实际上会……也许那是针对整数的，我记不清了。重点是，Ruby 有一堆这种微小的四字符便利方法。如果你需要将一个整数转换为它的二进制表示，如果你在 C++ 中通过……这可能需要一个 10 行的程序，而在 Ruby 中你实际上可以用大约 10 个字符搞定。而且，它有一大堆超级好用的方法，有时它们的名字很奇怪，但一旦你弄清楚它们叫什么，用起来就会非常非常爽。是的，对我来说，最棒的一点是 Ruby 拥有切片功能。因此你可以对数组或字符串进行切片，并给出一个小子范围，我想是用点点（dot dot）。
integers i can't remember the point is is that there's a bunch of these like tiny four character convenience methods where if you need to convert like an integer to its base two representation which is going to be like you know a 10 line program in c++ if you're going through it uh you can just do that in like literally 10 characters in ruby and uh yeah a ton of super nice can be sometimes they they have odd names but once you figure out what it's called uh they are very very nice to have yeah i think for me that the nicest thing there was that you have slices in Ruby. And so you can slice an array or slice a string and you can give like a little sub-range with, I think it was dot dot.
所以你可以写类似于零，你可以拿一个字符串，方括号，零，点点，三。那样会给你一个闭合方括号……会给你一个闭合方括号，并返回字符串的前四个字符。关于 Ruby，很棒的一点是，如果这个字符串只有两个字母长、两个字符长，也没关系，它会把这两个字符给你，并会说：“哦，我知道你想要四个，但（总共）两个就是你能拿到的全部了，我才不会为此抱怨呢。”而在 Java 中，如果你想要四个字符，而它只有两个。哦，抱歉，这里我得抛出一个异常。从这个角度来看，用 Ruby 做这件事要简单得多。
So you can say like zero, you can take a string, square bracket, zero, dot dot, three. And that'll give you a closed square bracket. And that'll give you a close square and that give you the first four characters of the string and the nice thing the nice thing about that is that uh well nice thing about ruby is that if the string is only like two letters long two two characters long it doesn't matter it'll give you those two and it'll say oh i know you wanted four but you know two is all you can get and i'm not going to complain about it. Whereas in Java, you want four characters, it's only got two. Oh, sorry, I'm throwing an exception here. So from that point of view, it was much simpler to do this in Ruby.
难道 Python 没有切片功能吗？对，Python 现在也有了。我不确定它们是不是那种会短路、只给你现有内容的切片方式。但我不太确定。也许当时 Python 还没有。我得承认，我对 Python 了解甚少。我勉强能看懂。对，关键是能看懂，但是……对，关键在于，Java 绝对没有。我知道现代 Java 引入了一些新的字符串设施和类型（比如 Java 20 或 21 引入的），这让事情变得容易得多。但在过去，字符串是不可变的，
But doesn't Python have slicing? Yeah, Python has that now too. I'm not sure if they have the short-circuiting only give you what it has. But I'm not sure. Maybe at the time Python didn't. I have to admit, I know
然后他们有了字符串缓冲区（StringBuffer）和字符串构建器（StringBuilder）。这就像是从一门你可以轻松操纵字符串的语言转过来一样，
very little Python. I can just about read it. Yeah. The key thing is read it, but... Yeah. The key thing is, though, is Java definitely did not. And like Java, I know modern Java has introduced, like 20 or 21 introduced some new string facilities and types that makes it way, way easier. But like back in the day, they had like, you know, strings were immutable,
在 Java 中，为了做一些非常简单的事情，你必须经历重重阻碍。如果你不习惯这样做，这会带来极大的不便。
and then they had string buffers and string builders. And it was just like coming from a language where you can, you know, manipulate strings easily. Uh, Java, it was,
甚至在 C++ 中，处理字符串也相当不错，你可以把两个字符串加在一起。这并不算太糟。
uh, you were jumping through hoops to do like very simple things. Um, which is, you know, a, a large inconvenience if, if you're not used to having to do that.
当然，你必须确保不会在字符串字面量、构造函数等方面栽跟头。但我记得 Java 的情况是，我当时想：“什么？我现在得去了解一个 Builder（构建器）吗？我只是想做点非常简单的事情。”他们会说：“哦，如果你想做涉及可变性的事情，你需要一个 Builder。”我当时想：“真的吗？”我想这个设计在 Java 5 或 Java 6 的时候就已经消失了。不管怎样，关于卢旺达的 ATM 情况，我还有几个问题：卢旺达所有的 ATM 现在都还在用运行着你的 Ruby 代码的那台小笔记本电脑吗？我想没有吧。我想……当时我们计划
Um, even in C plus plus, like dealing with strings is pretty, you can, you know, add two strings together. It's not, it's not too bad.
每台 ATM 配备一台笔记本电脑。好吧，好吧。那么，卢旺达的每台 ATM 现在都还在运行你写的这段 Ruby 代码吗？我完全不知道，但我猜答案绝对是否定的。我的意思是，当时我们在卢旺达拥有最好的互联网连接，网速是 360k 波特。对于我们年轻的听众来说，这可不算多。我知道现在通过住在在那儿的朋友了解到，他们国家拥有极好的互联网。所以情况现在已经变好了。但在当时，网速相当糟糕。此外，使用笔记本电脑的另一个好处是它有很好的电池续航，因此可以挺过停电，系统会继续运行，这也是相当重要的一点。关于笔记本电脑的最后一点是，它们的成本，怎么说，只要 200 美元，几乎不花什么钱。
Like, sure. You have to make sure you don't trip up on string literals and constructors and stuff but uh i remember like java was i was like what i gotta go learn about a builder now like i just i just want to do something real simple they're like well if you want to do something that involves mutability then you're going to need a builder and i was like really yeah i think that went away in by by java 5 or or Java 6 but anyway I have some questions about this Rwanda
但当时当有人使用 ATM 时，我们可能每秒才收到一条消息。可能收到 10 条消息就顶天了，所以根本不需要高性能。因此，Ruby 在那里完全没问题，系统没有任何速度限制。那么这是哪一年？这是 2010 年。这相当吻合。我刚才查了一下，我不知道这个数据有多准确，但它是美联储经济数据网站（Federal Reserve Economic Data）或类似的网站，上面说在 2010 年，只有 84 台，但仅仅三年之前只有 16 台。所以，这绝对与你说的吻合，而且根据该网站的数据，它在 2017 年达到了顶峰，全国共有 406 台。我本以为这个数字会达到数千台，但实际上它下降了。因此，截至 2022 年，该网站称卢旺达有 347 台 ATM。这非常令人惊讶，但后来我听说很多非洲国家使用……我不知道这个应用叫什么名字，但在中国相当于微信（Weixin），或者说他们有一个应用，我认为那是世界上第一个由肯尼亚公司开发的此类应用，他们称之为 X……不，是 M-Pesa。M-Pesa 在斯瓦希里语中是“钱”的意思，我相信……是的，很多银行业务都是在手机上进行的。
ATM situation so are all the ATMs in Rwanda still run by this netbook that's running your Ruby code I think no I think I think we had a net I think that we were going to have a netbook
没错。他们跳过了西方国家经历过的整整一个演进步骤，因为每个人在拥有电脑之前就已经有了手机。事实上，M-Pesa 甚至不是在智能手机上，而是在老旧的诺基亚手机上。你基本上需要在手机上安装这个微小的应用，然后输入你想汇款的人的手机号码，输入金额，点击发送，可能还会有另外一个小步骤，然后钱就汇出去了。关于笔记本电脑这件事，我想很多人的第一反应是：“哦，这太像打补丁了，你应该去买个树莓派（Raspberry Pi），把它放在某种设备上……”我认为当时还没有树莓派。对，那时候还没有树莓派。
per ATM okay okay so is each is each atm in rwanda still still running this uh ruby code that you wrote i have no idea but i suspect the answer is definitely no um i mean at at the time that they we had the best internet connection in rwanda and it was 360k baud so uh that's not a lot for our younger listeners um and i know now that they have excellent uh internet in the country from from talking to friends of mine who live there um so there yeah things are are fine now um but at the time it was pretty poor and also the other good thing about using a netbook was that it was like it had good battery life so you could survive survive power outages and the system would continue to work, which was also pretty important. And the last point about the netbook was that like these were they cost, what, 200 bucks and they were they cost nothing.
但电池的设计真是太聪明了。首先，它们超级便宜。其次，你的小树莓派或边缘计算设备没有内置的备用电池系统，但笔记本电脑有。是的，没错。它很便宜而且管用。所以，我非常喜欢那个故事。不过，当时全国之所以只有大约 14 台 ATM，是因为大约三年前，该国的保罗·卡加梅（Paul Kagame）总统
But we were only getting maybe when somebody was using the ATM, you might get a message every second. You might get like 10 messages and that was it so you didn't have you didn't have to be high powered at all um so that and ruby was therefore totally fine there was no speed constraints on the system so what year was this this was 2010 yeah so that that's's pretty consistent. I just looked it up, and I don't know how accurate this data is, but what is it, the Federal Reserve Economic Data website, something like that, and it says that in 2010, there was only 84, but just like three years earlier, it was 16. So, I mean, that's definitely consistent with what
去美国或其他地方旅行时，酒店要求扫描他的信用卡，而他没有信用卡，这让他感到有点尴尬。所以他回国后说：“好，我们要强制推行信用卡的普及，或者推广电子卡。”这就是那家公司成立的原因。有趣。是的，这真是一系列幸运或不幸的事件，导致了……所以在那之前，我想他们没有……我想这个图表上是怎么说的？它说在 2004 年只有两台。哦！所以他们当时确实有一些，对吧？是的。但我的意思是，如果只有两台，当你需要的时候，你刚好站在其中一台旁边几步远的几率几乎微乎其微，这种概率太低了。
you're saying and it peaked according to this site in 2017 they had 406 countrywide i was assuming that that number was going to be like in the thousands and it's actually gone down so currently as of 2022 this website says that there are 347 atms in rwanda and that is very i mean surprising but then i guess i've heard that a lot of african countries um use like i don't know what the name of the app is but like the equivalent in china is weishin or we they have a they have an app it was the first i think it was the first um app in the world it was done by a kenyan company and they called it x so mpesa mpesa is swahili for money i believe um yeah and a lot of banking happens on like cell phones yeah exactly they skipped a whole uh i don't know like evolution step that you know western
好吧。那么你在 2016 年回到了 C++ 怀抱，简介上是这么写的吗？在 2016 年，我又开始阅读相关资料，发现这门语言已经完全变了样，不再是我记忆中的那个样子了。我最后一次编写 C++ 大约是在 2000 年到 2001 年，之后我在那个阶段转到了 Java，然后 10 年后又转到了 Ruby。但在 2016 年回来时，发现有了移动语义（move semantics）。哇，这花了我好长时间才搞明白。
countries went through because everyone had cell phones before they had and in fact m-peso was it wasn't even on the smartphone it was on the old like nokia and you'd basically you'd actually they would install this tiny app onto the phone and you would then type in the phone number of the person you want to send you type in um an amount of money and you'd click send and and there'd be maybe one other thing and that would that would send your money um yeah the netbook thing you know i think a lot of people's first reaction is oh you're like that's so like hacky like yo you should go get a put it on a raspberry pi put it on some you know i don't think they had Raspberry Pis back then. No Raspberry Pis back then, no.
你的大脑被移动语义搞糊涂了，但从 2001 年到 2016 年，大概是 11 到 14 年间。你最喜欢的改动是什么？或者说，你怎么表达这个问题？从你当年写代码的时候起，最大的范式转变是什么？好吧，首先你拥有了一个标准库。这可不是我预料你会说的答案。不过我想这确实是一件大事。
But the battery thing, the battery thing is so clever. Like, one, they're super cheap. And two, like, you know, your little Raspberry Pi or your edge computing device doesn't have a battery backup system built into it, but a laptop does. Yeah. Yeah, it was cheap and it worked um so yeah i love that i love that story but the the reason why uh there were only like 14 or atms in the country at the time was about maybe three years before the president of the country paul kagama he had been
有些东西我们认为是理所当然的。是的，我的意思是，我们有了字符串。我们有了向量（vector）。虽然不是特别好的向量，但它们依然是字符串。我们有了向量。虽然不是特别好的向量，但它们依然是字符串。是的，我的意思是，完全如此。向量还不错。
he'd been somewhere traveling in maybe america or somewhere like that and the hotel had asked to take a scan of his credit card and he didn't have a credit card and he felt somewhat embarrassed about this so he when he came back home he said right we're going to mandate uh we're going to have credit cards for people or or electronic cards and that's why they they this company was started um interesting yeah that is a what do you call it a uh fortunate or unfortunate series of events that like you know leads to and so before that point i guess they they didn't have i guess what does this graph say it says yeah in 2004 there was only two oh okay so they actually had they had some then right yeah but i mean it's if it's two i mean odds are there you know uh that you're going to find
向量，你拥有了所有这些实用的东西，比如映射（map）、哈希映射（hash map）等等。这太棒了。这是旧版本的语言从未拥有过的。帕斯卡（Pascal）语言，我想它没有……不，它没有任何标准库。它有标准输出。你可以把东西打印到文件和控制台里，但仅此而已。有趣。
yourself standing next to one when you need one is pretty astronomically low, the probability of that. Yeah. All right. So you found your way back to C++ in, what did the bio say, 2016? In 2016, I started reading stuff about it again and found that the language had totally changed from what I remembered. I last wrote c++ about 2000 2001 and then i switched to to java at that stage and then 10 years later i switched to ruby but 2016 came back there was move semantics wow that was like that took me
那么 Java，因为 Java 以拥有庞大的标准库而闻名，它是 90 年代那些率先自带你可以直接使用而无需自己编写的代码的语言吗？我想是的。不过 Smalltalk 也有。Smalltalk 有，是的。Smalltalk 有……对，Smalltalk 有一个庞大的库。
forever to figure out what was your what was your you were, you know, your mind was, you know, befuddled by move semantics, but from 2001 to 2016, that's, I guess, 11 and 14. What was like the biggest, or I guess, how do you phrase the question? What was your favorite change? And like, what was the biggest paradigm shift from when you were coding? Well, you had a standard library for a start. That's not what I was expecting you to say. But I guess that is a big deal.
绝对是的。我想 Java 也是 Smalltalk 的后代，尽管……其实不算。其实不算。某种程度上算吧。人们听到面向对象就会想到这两门语言。但是，是的，我想你可以辩称 Java 实际上是某种其他语言。我在想。
Things we take for granted. Yeah, I mean, we had strings. We had vectors. Not very good ones, but they're still strings. We had vectors. Not very good ones, but they're still strings. Yeah. I mean, exactly. Vector's okay. Yeah.
我正试图回忆 Lisp，那是我在大学里最喜欢的语言。那里面有很多东西。你可以做很多……但我不知道……我不认为……好吧，对于 Lisp，你拥有核心，然后其他所有东西都是附加上去的。
Vector, you had all these, you know, useful, you know, you have maps, hash maps and whatever. It's fantastic. And that's something that the old languages never had. You know, Pascal, I don't think had... No, it didn't have any standard. It had standard output. You could print stuff to files into the console, but that was it. Interesting.
我觉得我听说过 Common Lisp 以拥有海量随箱自带的功能而闻名。这既是优点也是缺点，因为 Lisp 以这种非常小巧、核心、同像性（homo-iconic）、即代码即数据的特性而闻名。但后来 Common Lisp 走向了另一个方向——这只是我听别人做过相关演讲后的印象——它自带了大量的东西，某种程度上破坏了那种纯粹性。核心虽然还在某个地方，但它自带了一大堆东西。不过说实话，我从来没有编写过 Common Lisp。是的，我也没有。我用过一种叫做 Franz Lisp 的 Lisp 语言，里面有很多双关语。Franz Lisp？F-R-A-N-S？不，是 F-R-A-N-Z。
So Java, I mean, because Java famously has a massive standard library. Was that the first language of the languages back in the 90s that kind of started to ship with code that you could use and not have to write yourself? I would think so. Although Smalltalk had. Smalltalk had, yes. Smalltalk had a Smalltalk, yes. Smalltalk had a big library.
Franz，就像作曲家弗朗茨·李斯特（Franz Liszt）一样。它有很多关于这位 19 世纪作曲家的笑话。你听说过弗朗茨·李斯特吗，布莱斯？没有，对康纳来说这一定是一门非常冷门的语言。我的意思是，当我在学习《计算机程序的构造和解释》（SICP）时，我曾制作过一个视频，内容就像是 LISP 的历史。我发现了大量我从未听说过的 LISP 语言，比如 PicoLisp。我不知道，还有一堆我听说过的。
Absolutely. And I guess Java is also a descendant of Smalltalk, you know, even though. It's not really. It's not really. Kind of, yeah. People hear object-oriented and they think of both of those languages. But, yeah, I guess you could argue that, you know, there's some other language that Java is. I'm wondering.
还有一个叫做 Dylan 的语言，我想是微软出品的。哦，听起来那是后来才有的。听起来很……我想那是微软出品的。哦，听起来那是后来才有的。听起来要晚得多。对，对。那是 90 年代的事。但无论如何，重点是，Lisp 的世界非常广阔。人们通常认为只有原版的 LISP、Scheme 和 Racket，还有 Clojure。但在幕后，还有大约 50 种其他的 Lisp 语言，它们在语言特性等方面各不相同。关于 Lisp，你刚才说它是同像性的，
I'm trying to remember Lisp, which was my favorite language in college. That had a lot of stuff in it. You could do a lot of... But I'm not sure if... I don't think... Well, with Lisp, you've got the core, and then everything else is kind of added on.
这意味着数据就是程序，程序就是数据。我对这个很感兴趣。好吧，我很久以前就很感兴趣，但当时谈到了奎因（Quine）程序。你们知道什么是奎因吗？知道，知道。奎因就是……我以前听说过，但我不记得了。奎因是一个程序，当它运行时会产生它自己的源代码，
I feel like I've heard that Common Lisp famously also had massive amounts that like shipped with it. And that was kind of both a pro and a con because Lisp is famous for being this very small, nuclear, homo-iconic, you know, data is code kind of thing. But then Common Lisp went this other direction and this is all just third party from having heard people give talks on this is like it shipped with a ton of stuff that kind of like ruined that like it still had the core somewhere inside it but it shipped with a bunch of stuff but i've honestly never programmed a common list but yeah i haven't either i used i used a lisp called franz lisp which had lots of puns. Franzlisp? F-R-A-N-S? No, F-R-A-N-Z.
它可不仅仅是去读文件然后吐出答案……但我记得我曾为 Lisp 编写过一个奎因程序，大概只有六行长。这倒挺符合的，确实如此。但是，如果你尝试为 C++ 编写一个，那可能需要 50 行左右。我知道曾有一个很棒的演讲，我记得最近（也许是过去三年内）有一个关于奎因程序以及如何编写奎因的闪电演讲（lightning talk）。我不记得了，我猜做演讲的人是个法国人。我猜是的，不过我也可能记错。我们会找到……好吧，我会做点搜索。是的，外面绝对有很多这样的演讲。有一组著名的奎因程序，虽然我记不得名字了，但它们会生成……这是一个巨大的循环，它以一条咬着自己尾巴的龙或蛇来命名。
Franz, as in Franz Liszt, the composer. It had lots of jokes about the 19th century composer. Have you heard of Franz Liszt, Bryce? No, it's got to be a pretty obscure language for Connor. I mean, I made a whole video at one point when I was working through the structure and interpretation of computer programs that was like the history of LISPs. And I discovered a ton of LISPs that I had never heard of, like PicoLisp. And I don't know, there's a bunch I have heard of.
最初它只支持几种语言，但现在已经增加到了一百多种，我不知道是不是有一百多种。所以它的运作方式是：Java 生成 C++，C++ 生成 Ruby，代码穿梭于上百种不同的语言中，一路倒推回来，所以每一个……有没有哪个奎因程序足够简单，我们可以在播客里直接讨论一下？因为我正试图在脑海中想象其中一个是如何运作的。主要的问题在于，你必须处理引号以及如何输出引号。因为基本上你的奎因程序将会是这样的：比如 `int main`，然后你会写类似 `printf` 或 `std::cout` 之类的内容，加上一个长长的字符串。
There's one also called Dylan, I think, that was out of Microsoft. Oh, that sounds later. That sounds a lot, I think, that was out of Microsoft. Oh, that sounds later. That sounds a lot later. Yeah, yeah. That was the 90s. But anyways, the whole point is like, you know, there's a whole world of LISPs out there. People think of like there's the LISP LISP, there's Scheme and Racket, and then there's Closure. But like behind the scenes, there's like 50 other LISPs that all vary in their language features and whatnot. The thing about lisp, you were saying it's homo-iconic,
其中的问题在于，你必须处理额外的双引号，而它们会被吃掉，所以你必须把它们生成出来，这就是所有技巧的用武之地。你必须运用
which means data is program and program is data. And I got interested there. Well, I was interested a long time ago, but there was about quines. Do you guys know what a quine is? Yeah, yeah. A quine is... I've heard it before, but i don't remember aquine is a program that when run produces its own uh source code um and it doesn't just do like you know read the file
某种程度上的交互技巧。不过你懂奎因的本质是什么，对吧，布莱斯？我懂它的本质。但我还是想看一个简单的。就像我说的，有个家伙做了一个闪电演讲，他在大约 7 分钟内展示了如何编写一个奎因程序。那是过去几年里在某个 C++ 会议上讲的。好了各位，我们要做一个小小的微型绕道。我不会共享屏幕，但我把网页打开了——因为我们不会在 ADSP 播客里共享屏幕了，布莱斯有时候会这么做，
and spit out the answer um but i remember writing aquine for lisp and it was like six lines long and that checks out that's yeah and and and but if you try to do it for for c++ it's probably i think 50 lines or something i know there was a great talk there was a i think there was a lightning talk there i want recently well maybe the last three years about quines and how to write a quine and it was i can't remember i think that the i think the person who gave it was french i suspect they were but i could be wrong we'll find uh well i'll do some searching yeah there's definitely a bunch of talks out there there's there's a famous set of quines which i'm not gonna remember the name of but it's like they generate it's a it's a huge loop like and it's named after a dragon their snake that's
因为他不在乎亲爱的听众你。但我会在乎。确实如此。但我会在乎。我现在在 `rosettacode.org/wiki/Quine` 网页上。我数不清有多少种语言，但粗略估计大概有 200 到 300 种。所以我往下滚动，我来给你们报个大概的数字。80 种……汇编语言（assembly）看起来有几百种。ABAP 看起来有 30 行，尽管里面有一堆额外的东西。ACL2 是 6 行，而且他们实际上有一个更短的单行版本。我不知道 ACL2 是不是一种语言。
eating its own tail yeah where like it started off with like a few languages but now it's up to like i don't know if it's 100 plus but so it's like you know the java generates the c++ generates the ruby and it goes through a hundred different languages all the way back and so you know every is there one of these that's simple enough that we could uh like talk through it right now on the podcast just because like i'm i'm i'm trying to mentally imagine like how one of these works. The main problem is that you've got to handle quotation marks and emitting quotation marks. Because basically what your quine is going to be, it's going to be like int main bracket bracket. And then you're going to have like printf or std cout or whatever and a big long string and the
那是一种 Lisp 吗？我从没听说过这个。如果我点击 ACL2，上面写着“ACL2 是一种逻辑和编程语言，你可以在其中对计算机系统进行建模，并使用工具来帮助你证明这些模型的属性”。ACL2 表示应用型通用 Lisp（applicative common lisp）的计算逻辑。啊，通用 Lisp。你看，它是一种 Lisp 语言。啊，通用 Lisp。你看，它是一种 Lisp 语言。
problem with that is that you've got to handle the extra double quotes and they get swallowed so you have to produce them and that's where all the tricks come in and you have to use
是的，没问题。A-C-L。我直接跳到 Bash 的那个。我的思维方式就是这样。哦，看那个！APL。同样是单行。不出所料。
the circumventive interaction I understand the And that's where all the tricks come in. And you have to use a certain amount of interaction. You understand the essence of what a coin is though, right, Bryce? I understand the essence. I would still like to see a simple one. As I said, a guy did a lightning talk and he showed how to write a coin in about seven minutes. It was in one of the c++ conferences over the last few years all right folks we're taking a little mini detour i will not share the screen but i have up because we don't do that on adsp the podcast anymore bryce sometimes does
康纳太高兴了。现在我来为听众读一下这段代码。听起来很像 C++。它是 1 旋转，矩阵展开（ravel）。它是矩阵展开交换，9 重塑（reshape），然后是单引号、单引号、单引号。内在的引号里面是：1 旋转，矩阵展开，交换，9 重塑。有趣。所以这到底在干什么？基本上，它对本质上完全相同的东西执行了一个空操作（no-op），或者说是一个小型操作。9 重塑将为你提供
because he doesn't care about you dear listener i. I, however, do. That's true. I, however, do. And I am at rosettacode.org slash wiki slash quine. And I am not going to be able to count how many languages, but we're looking at roughly I'd estimate 200 or 300. So I'm going to scroll and I'm just going to give you the guesses. So 80, 80 assembly looks to be a couple hundred. ABAP looks to be 30 lines, although there's a bunch of extra stuff. ACL2 is six lines and they actually have a shorter one that is a single line. I don't know if ACL2 is the language.
这段代码两次，因为你的字符串里面有 1、2、3、4、4、5、6 个字符。当你在一个字符串上执行重塑时——这实际上类似于我们刚才在 Ruby 中讨论的内容，只不过在那种情况下，我们试图获取超过我们拥有的内容，它给回你的只是那里面存在的东西——而在 APL 中，当你对重塑执行此操作时（这基本上是尝试重塑字符串的形状），如果你指定了更多，它实际上会循环。
Is that a lisp? I've never heard of this. If I click on ACL2, it says ACL2 is the language. What is ACL2? Is that a lisp? Never heard of this. If I click on ACL2, it says, ACL2 is a logic and programming language in which you can model computer systems together with a tool to help you prove properties of those models. ACL2 denotes a computational logic for applicative common lisp. Ah, common lisp. You see, it's a lisp language. Ah, common lisp. You see, it's a lisp language.
所以在这个例子中，如果你有 1、2、3、4，而你试图执行“取 10 个”，你最终会得到 1、2、3、4、1、2、3、4、1、2。你可以争论哪种行为更好：是 APL 的行为，还是 Ruby 的行为？重点是，这就是 APL 的工作原理。我不确定听众是否能听懂。布莱斯，你看懂 Bash 的那个了吗？Bash 的那个，是的，我
Yeah, okay. A-C-L. I'm jumping down to the bash one. This is how my mind works. Oh, look at that. A-P-L. Single line as well. Unsurprisingly.
看过 C++ 和 Bash 的版本，Bash 的版本没什么帮助，因为它们直接作弊并做了一些可怕的事情。但是，嘿，编写奎因程序时可没有作弊这一说！奎因的核心要点就是生成你最初编写的源代码。这就是唯一的规则。根本没有作弊这种说法。我们几分钟前不是刚说过你不能读取源文件吗？没错。那是作弊。
Connor is so pleased. Now I'm going to read this out for the listener. And it's going to sound like C++. It's one rotate, ravel. It's ravel commute, nine reshape, and then single quote, single quote, single quote. And then inside the inner quotes, one rotate, ravel, commute, nine reshape. Interesting. So what is that doing? Basically, it's basically kind of performing a no op, I think, or a small operation on what is essentially just going to be the exact same thing. And the nine reshape is going to give you this,
好吧。我收回刚才的话。我相当确定 Bash 的其中一个示例本质上是……我觉得它其实没有读取源文件，而是……它把脚本所在的文件映射进来了，然后直接把那个打印出来。哦，我刚才突然意识到，当我在 APL 中说 ravel（矩阵展开）时，那实际上是一元运算（monadic），它是二元定义（dyadic）。所以它应该是串联（catenate）。我想看 Makefile 的那个。这可能是四集播客系列的第 1 部分。
this code twice, because you have one, two, three, four, four five six characters inside your string and when you reshape on a on a string so similar to actually what we were talking about in ruby earlier instead in in that case we had we were trying to take more than we had where we gave and it gave you back just what what was there in apl when you do that with a reshape which is basically trying to to reshape the shape of your string if you specify more it actually cycles so in this it'll cycle
请务必在你的播客应用中或访问 adspthepodcast.com 查看节目 Shownotes，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及 GitHub 讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下评论、想法和问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是我们的标语。
you know if you've got 1, 2, 3, 4 and you're trying to do a take 10 you'll end up with 1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2 which you can argue which behavior is better is it the APL behavior, is it the Ruby behavior the point is that's how APL works and I'm not sure if that made sense to the listener bryce have you made sense of the bash the bash yeah i've
我们的标语是“洒满信息 sprinkles 的混乱”。本期节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
looked at the c++ and the bash ones and the bash ones are not very helpful because they just cheat and do awful things but i i hey there's no such thing as cheating when writing a quine the whole point of a quine is that you just generate the source code that you initially wrote. That's the only rule. There's no such thing as cheating. Didn't we say just a few minutes ago that you can't read in the source file? Correct. That's cheating.
我看过C++和bash的，bash的那些不太有用，因为它们只是作弊并做一些糟糕的事情，但我，嘿，写一个奎因程序（quine）可没有什么作弊之说，奎因的核心意义就是生成你最初编写的源代码。这就是唯一的规则。根本没有作弊这回事。我们几分钟前不是刚说过不能读取源文件吗？没错。那才是作弊。
Alright. I stand corrected. And I'm fairly certain that the first one of the bash examples here is essentially... I don't think it actually reads in the source file but it um it maps in no that's what it does pretty much it maps in the file where the script is and then it just prints that out oh and i just realized when i said ravel in apl that was actually the monadic it was was the dyadic definition. So it would have been catenate. I want to see the make one. This is probably part one of a four-part episode series.
好吧。我收回刚才的话。我相当确定这里第一个bash示例本质上……我不认为它真的读取了源文件，但它，嗯，它映射了——不对，它差不多就是把脚本所在的那个文件映射进来，然后把它打印出来。哦，我刚意识到，刚才我在APL里说ravel的时候，其实用的是一元定义，而那是二元定义。所以那应该是catenate。我想看看那个make的示例。这可能是四期系列节目的第一部分。
Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to the GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline.
请务必查看你的播客应用程序或访问adspthepodcast.com上的节目笔记，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及可以留下评论、想法和问题的GitHub讨论区链接。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝有个美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。其实不是这个标语。
Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的标语是“洒满信息 sprinkles 的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。